are you swallowing them whole you're
eating them so fast are they even
touching your tongue
yeah why aren't you having any angela oh
i ate so many
already when no one was looking
yeah right
my baby's dieting
she wants to fit into a special
child-sized wedding gown for our big day
why do those exist it's from my pageant
days i was miss tiny mid-atlantic bride
when i was 10. probably heard of it
brownies is that
pastry cubes made of sugar and fat no
thank you i'll stick with my jerky so
why'd you come in here to socialize and
then form ooh brownies i'm taking two so
i can parcel them up
and eat them
at my leisure later on much healthier
you're taking two
yeah um but one of them is for tubby
yeah why don't you send that to him in
costa rica
um i'm just gonna hand it to him right
now okay weirdo
why is that why is that weird she said
she was gonna give it to him right now
she's probably going to because they sit
next to each other yeah they used to
toby works here again oh can you imagine
oh no oh you don't know
i don't know
what you should probably just meander
back there take a look see if he's
if he's back dare i
you know what i'm going to
for old time's sake
great practical joke jim got me go to
the annex
no god
no god please no no
no
no
so you got mugged huh mr donaghy and you
caught the guy who did it good for you
oh no len uh tracy is helping me with
this but i can see how you went there i
have a criminal skull shape len
commissioner kelly and i are friends we
have competing columns and irish
arguments weekly america's only all caps
magazine but ray hasn't returned my
phone call and i know that you were once
a uh police officer i was part of a
special task force of very young looking
cops who infiltrated high schools
[Music]
how do you do fellow kids what oh air
hockey basketball we could play that
oh
whack-a-mole brothers or sisters three
brothers really
two are in the marines one's a cup
vegetarian
no i love meat
what's your blood type o negative
universal donor universal donor
angela versus isabelle
height advantage isabelle
birthing hips advantage isabelle
remaining childbearing years
advantage isabel
legal obligation
advantage angelo
[Laughter]
what's so funny oh no no no you're a
smart guy
clearly picked up some flashy tricks but
you made one crucial mistake
you forgot about the essence of the game
it's about the cones
move my abbott to the ocean hex which
moves my brinksman to the devil's lair
and pushes my farmer yes my humble
farmer directly
into the central cone
[Applause]
yeah man we did it this whole company is
ours oh no it's not that's mine it's all
mine for the record
i did invent this game but it doesn't
even matter because i won and i get
another chance to prove that there is
something truly special about pawnee yes
there is it's the home of the architect
let's talk i'm on top of the world
captain diaz sent us the list of favors
she needs us to do for she didn't hold
back first she wants us to move all her
furniture into storage okay then file
her taxes for really and then she wants
us to type up and email these letters to
pimento in argentina are they sexual in
nature crazy sexual but we can't say no
she's behind bars and we made a promise
right you're right oh also
she's worried about her motorcycle
sitting idle so she wants us to take it
out once a day here
i think you should do this you're more
the biker type i've seen you use a
toothpick in public motorcycles are
death machines i have three kids i'm not
risking it are you saying my life
matters less because i don't conform to
society's heteronormative child-centric
ideals are you really playing the gay
card right now yes queen
aristotle was plato's student and
aristotle believes that your character
is voluntary because it's just the
result of your actions which are under
your control
for example right now you have made the
insane choice to ignore the person who
is literally trying to save you from
eternal damnation no yeah i'm listening
uh i just
are we sure we should be paying
attention to these guys it's like who
died and left aristotle in charge of
ethics
plato
are you sure everything will be all
right if april goes to vet school there
are no sure things in life son but you
two seem pretty solid to me change is
good i guess not to me leslie's going
around asking everybody if they're
better off than they were a year ago
all i care about is that i'm the same
if i'm the same as i was a year ago i'm
happy wait i forgot
who the hell is pregnant what i found a
pregnancy test at your cabin and i
checked with all the girls who were
there it wasn't any of them
hey hello darling what a surprise hey
can we talk maybe in private
[Music]
all right fill me in tell me everything
i missed won't take long only three
things happened terry chipped his tooth
and had a lisp for a week
listen up stephen
i'm sorry did i say something amusing to
you answer me you son of a [ __ ]
number two santiago and boyle wore the
same outfit to work one day
how does it look better on you
and captain banned headphones from the
office due to the gina incident
i know
you just got yourself kicked out of your
apartment
oh i don't care i don't really like that
place that much anyway i'll just move
oh really who's gonna take you in
you're messy
you're a klutz you spill everything and
you leave the volume on the tv
way too loud yeah
maybe i'll just move in with my
boyfriend cause he's kind of a slob too
okay here
let's do it
no i um well i'm not gonna i'm
i'm not gonna move in with anyone unless
i'm engaged
am i not proposing yet um
i don't know oh no well
that's coming
oh right now
no i'm not gonna do it right here that
would be rather lame
okay so then when
pam i'm not gonna tell you i hate to
break it to you but that's not how that
works oh right yeah
wait i'm serious
it's happening okay and when it happens
it's going to kick your ass beasley
so
stay sharp
i've been warned
i am not kidding
got it a week after we started dating
i'm afraid i have some very bad news
i chris trager after several sustained
hours of diarrhea combined with violent
coughing and a devastating fever
followed by even more diarrhea
have succumbed to the avian flu
i'm dead
you